first we can go to Western Satan speaks
Jeremy Hunt who is the chair of the
House of Commons health Follette
committee the UK's longest-serving
health secretary thank you very much for
being on the program today this is the
biggest challenge our generation has
faced it feels as if it's the biggest
health crisis since the 1918 Spanish flu
pandemic and yet it was only the last
few days that the government's closed
schools restaurants bars and cafes have
we been a bit slow off the mark well
because of the contact tracing that's
been done by public health England which
i think is probably in the best in
Europe the virus has been a few weeks
behind the other major European
countries and that has given us time to
get things organized and time to learn
about the best measures to do
the crucial thing now is that if
everyone does what these social
distancing measures require if we do
what the prime minister says if we don't
visit our our mother for Mother's Day
all those kinds of things then we have a
chance of avoiding the the terrible
impact on the health system that we saw
in Italy so I think it's all to pay for
I think it is absolutely possible still
just to avoid what we've seen but
everyone is very very worried and the
virus is growing still very fast and it
is very very disappointing when people
don't obey the simple instructions that
are being given out because it's not
your own life you're risking necessarily
but you could be risking someone else's
life it's interesting hearing the words
you use in there just we have a chance
how troubling do you find the situation
that we're currently in it is deeply
worrying and you know I spent my time
when I was health secretary before being
incredibly impressed by the work of
people on the front line but I think now
when people see that doctors in other
countries have lost their lives on the
front line against coronavirus and they
see the personal risks that our NHS
staff are taking
particularly London where it is very
very pressured at the moment I think we
need to reflect that we actually owe it
to them that we do everything we can to
slow the spread of the virus because
they are putting their necks out for us
and we just have that basic
responsibility to to those NHS frontline
staff who doing so much to do our bit
and slow the spread of the virus I mean
this week Norfolk Park Hospital in
Harrow in the North London area declared
a critical incident after running out of
intensive care beds I mean we're only at
the beginning it feels of the battle
against coronavirus and yet hospitals
already struggling is the NHS ready well
in terms of pandemic preparedness the
NHS was globally recognized as the
second best prepared system in the world
by an independent American think tank so
I think it is a pretty well prepared
system but the truth is that you know
Italy was a well-funded is a well-funded
healthcare system it's a well respected
health care system and we've seen the
impact there would that a pandemic can
have so no healthcare system can really
sustain the kind of pressure that we're
seeing when this virus gets out of
control so that's why what happens in
the next week is going to be absolutely
critical speaking to Jeremy Corbyn
earlier he seemed to be suggesting that
the NHS is not prepared we started off
with 5,000 ventilators around 4,000
intensive care beds you were health
secretary of course from 2012 until 2018
the longest-serving ever do you take
some responsibility for the state of the
NHS at this minute as we're about to
face a global pandemic of course and
when I was health secretary I was
someone who believed that we did need a
big increase in resources for the NHS
which is why I fought very hard for that
20 billion pound increase that big
increase so I do think the NHS needs
more resources but I think we also have
to recognize this is a different debate
this is a debate about how you cope with
a pandemic that can blow over any health
system anywhere in the world and the
only way that we can stop that happening
is to suppress the spread of the virus
and that means each and every one of us
recognizing that if we get the virus
today because of the information period
we might end up in hospital in two weeks
time so what we do today massively
matters and if we want to have any
chance at all of stopping the NHS
falling over then we have to obey to the
letter all the advice that's going out
about keeping apart from each other
particularly keeping apart from elderly
relatives and people who are at risk
taking all those measures that are
completely unprecedented but will help
to save our lives and those of our loved
ones I mean we're all having to get our
heads around the massive changes we're
gonna have to make to our lives whether
you've got a young child whether you've
got teenager who is not gonna be able to
sit their exams if you can't see your
elderly mum today on Mother's Day you've
got young family what kind of changes
are you having to make well it's my
daughter's eighth birthday today and you
know obviously she's not having a
birthday party and there'll be many
children like that up and down the
country who are experiencing big
disappointment about things they were
hoping to do that they're not able to do
but I think everyone understands that in
a situation like this actually as Jeremy
Corbyn was saying just now there is a
sense of community spirit a sense of
everyone pulling together and we
absolutely can get through this as a
country we've we've been through huge
challenges in our history but we also
have to recognize that it's in our hands
whether we're successful or not
and the extent to which we comply with
all the advice that we're being given is
going to be absolutely critical
oh really happy birthday to your
daughter if you want to wish her a happy
birthday then do feel free as well and
happy birthday Anna and we heard from
them we've been talking a lot about the
NHS staff and how they really are on the
frontline of the crisis and there's been
reports that they're not having a
protective equipment
they need many doctors writing into the
Sunday Times today saying that they feel
abandoned the chair of the British
Medical Association was on the show last
weekend saying that there's not enough
testing of NHS staff is this something
that you're worried about well I think a
lot has changed in the last week and we
have had lorries on the road pretty much
every day going around the country we
had a very difficult Select Committee
hearing on Tuesday in which we raised
these issues with the Simon Stephens and
the NHS really has moved heaven and
earth to get protective equipment out to
every hospital the concerns that are
being raised are that for treating
coronavirus patients the advice
previously was to use these very high
specification masks the FFP three masks
and the sort of the full gowns hazmat
suits and that has changed to only using
that very high grade equipment when
you're putting on ventilators and so on
so I think the solution to that if it's
possible is to order more of that high
grade equipment more of those grounds
more of the FFP three masks and - one of
those as quickly as possible because
those are clearly the highest grade
equipment and those the things that the
medics would feel most comfortable
wearing and would obviously all like to
give them that degree of comfort but I
do think we need to recognize that a lot
has improved in the last few days and we
haven't got much time left but I do want
to get a quick question in about the
economic package announced by the
government this week lots of help there
for many people across the country of
course but there has been some focus on
the self-employed who would be eligible
for just 94 pounds a week if they are
unable to work is that enough well
clearly 94 pounds a week is not enough
for most people to be able to survive on
but in reality this is the most
comprehensive economic package that has
been announced anywhere in the Western
world and it's a huge step for the
government to do that and it's a vote of
confidence that when we get to the other
side when we put the virus behind us
whenever we're able to do that we will
be able to get back
to normal life and the quickest way to
do that is to avoid having 1 to 3
million people losing their jobs in the
next few months because that would
create a much longer term denting
confidence so I think it's an
unprecedented and very very important
package and I'm sure the chance we'll be
looking at self-employed as well and
doing what we can to support them going
forward